jetzt schauen wir aber auf einen ganz
ganz ganz besonderen momenten erlebt man
einmal im leben und man steht mächtig
unter druck und weiß hier darf nichts
schiefgehen und dann dann passiert es
doch schauen wir auf diese bilder aus
großbritannien und rums sechs stunden
lang müssen diese wachmänner dort am
sagt der queen waffen und er hat vorher
schon viel geschwankt und dann
fällt richtig los live kameras ging er
sofort weg es ist vor den augen der
gesamten reihe family das gab ein
ausschlag in die stille für alle hörbar
und er wurde dann natürlich sofort
verarztet es ist auch mit ihm alles okay
aber dennoch ich denke auch was ging in
ihm vor er wurde es war nicht viele
wachmänner der diese ehre zuteil wurden
dort direkt vor dem sarg der queen zur
stehen und dann steht man dermaßen unter
druck und dann streikt der k13 sony bild
das ja eigentlich ein symbol ist für
diesen ganz lang trauer marathon und
dass das ganze land dass die briten
wirklich alles geben in diesen momenten
in diesem letzten trauer moment noch mal
für ihre kliniken ganz ganz lange stehen
bis zur erschöpfung das machen ja gerade
hunderttausende briten das was ich hier
gerade sehen das ist die warteschlange
ja der live ticker zur warteschlange vor
westminster hall in london da können sie
immer im netz sehen so lange dauert es
gerade wie viele kilometer ist das wie
lang muss sich anstehen um es noch zu
schaffen zum sarg der queen man steht
auf jeden fall lange lange lange und
sollte sich den tag frei in vier tage
wird die queen dort ja sein dann kann
man abschied nehmen die mir direkt
dorthin stellen uns mit an in diese
schlange der wartenden kai feldhaus
unser chefreporter mittendrin seit den
frühen morgenstunden stehen dort die
menschen um abschied zu nehmen
wie lange und wie schafft man das
überhaupt damit es einem in dieser
schlange nicht so geht wie dem wachmann
am sarg
wir stehen seit 3 stunden wie patricia
und das geheimnis sind bananen
müsliriegel und gutes schuhwerk dann
kommt man da nicht ganz gut voran es ist
erstaunlich gut organisiert das muss man
sagen wir sind schon an der lände fritz
rau steht am 23
das hat immer was los
vielleicht gibt es auch mal da drüben
des westminster da liegt die queen hier
können sie also quasi fast schon sehen
wir haben drei stunden bis sie gebraucht
was erstaunlich schnell ist da könnte
ich so ganz genau absehen wie lange es
von hier noch dauert weil wir müssen die
sicherheitskontrolle aber die leute
schlagen sich alle sehr sehr tapfer
wehrenden auch draußen stehst können wir
nämlich schon mal den blick reinwerfen
kai während du sprichst sehen wir das
leitbild dort geradeaus westminster hall
also diejenigen die wir hier sehen die
sind ein bisschen weiter vorne in der
schlange die haben sich dann aber halt
auch früher angestellt kein muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen die sind jetzt hier
drin wie weit ist das von dir entfernt
also heißt es gerade gezeigt trüben das
scheint mir noch ein weiter weg kannst
du es abschätzen etwa wann du es rein
geschafft hast wenn wir dich dann sehen
gleich vor dem sarg der queen
also das sind über die brücke von hier
über die brücke würde ich sagen
vielleicht noch 500 meter allerdings ist
dann vor der westminster hall so
labyrinth abgesteckt wo man dann auch
einzeln durch muss dann geht es
natürlich sicherheitskontrolle der
werden wie taschen durchleuchtet es hieß
vorhin das könnte noch drei stunden
dauern ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen
die leute wenn ihr so dermaßen durch
durchgeschleust wie rauschen hier so
durch ich könnte mir schon vorstellen
dass ich in der stunde da bei der queen
am sarg stellen brechen wir ja immer
wieder unter anderem dass man endlich da
der große moment brauchst du dass du in
vier stunden es geschafft hast und dann
dann darf man dort in ruhe verharren in
gedanken im stillen gebet in schönen
erinnerungen
da hat man ein paar sekunden und weiter
geht's und dann ist der moment vorbei
oder
ja das ist ja dass ihre will man steht
hier 3456 gestern bis zu neun stunden an
oder die leute wir gezeltet haben und
dann ist es nicht so dass man noch
gemütlich am sarg stehen und seinen
seinen gedanken nachhängen oder ein
gebet sprechen kann wir laufen einfach
weiter das heißt alles worauf wir
hinarbeiten in dieser schlange wir jetzt
seit drei stunden ist dann innerhalb von
wahrscheinlich eine minute oder zwei
vorbei ich bin auch sehr gespannt wie
einprägsam dass dann am ende sein wird
aber das kann ich euch nachher berichten
das nächste mal schalten dann war ich im
idealfall schon drin ja das hongkonger
für uns und für dich wir sind gespannt
dann auf deine eindrücke wie sehr du
diesen moment schildern kann zudem du
dann vor dem sarg der queen stehst unser
bild chefreporter kai feldhaus
westminster hall in london
[Musik]